live on the Rich Eisen show from the
Minnesota Timberwolves head coach Tom
Thibodeau here on the show
how are you coach thanks rich thanks for
element ank you for calling in so I I
hadn't seen it I'm assuming you were at
the podium for Jimmy Butler's press
conference that just went down in
Minnesota did you take down his phone
number when he gave it out or I assumed
or he had it
yeah you know I don't know how that will
go for him but he'll be pretty busy so
he gave out his phone number for all the
critics to call him that is what
happened yeah that's what fuels his fire
how surprised were you when you heard
him give out that phone number now that
Julie is a Jimmy hater I obviously
coached them and he's a very driven guy
and I don't think it really matters to
him whether it's praise or criticism you
know whatever he can use to drive them
that's what he'll do and there were a
lot of great moments for him in Chicago
as well so you know I don't know where
that was coming from but sometimes that
happens but he's a pretty unique guy to
see what he's done where he's come from
to be the 30th player taken in the first
round to three-time all-star an Olympian
gold medalist two-way player he just
keeps getting better and better so what
do you think he will do for your team
with the youngster I think a lot I think
the big thing is where he is age was 2
he's 27 just entering the prime of his
career so a lot of the things that he's
just gone through that's what Carl and
wig are going through right now so I
think just having somebody like that
will be very beneficial to them but I
think the fact that he's he's such a
great defensive player and obviously we
have to improve in that area but just
how unselfish he is also his ability to
make plays he's always been a high
assist guy you can play them at the
point you can play them at the floor you
can play on both wing positions and then
defensively same thing he does things in
multiples as well as anyone in the
league big time multiple effort guy
place can defend five positions so I
think that type of leadership and the
thing that I really admire and respect
about them
his his work ethic is really special I
think obviously you can't do the things
that he's done without a lot of talent
but it's his drive his intelligence in
his love of the game usually as guys
achieve things sometimes they let up
this guy's kept the hunger of a rookie
throughout his career and he wants to
get better and I think that type of
examples perfect for our team Tom
Thibodeau the coach of the Timberwolves
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
would you agree with the assessment of
reading of the NBA room by Daryl Morey
the general manager of the Rockets that
we are in the midst of an arms race a
weapons race in the NBA that we haven't
seen based on how the Warriors have put
their team together yeah I think when
you study what's going on in the league
I would say that's probably pretty
accurate you know obviously everyone's
chasing Golden State and you look at
Cleveland they're doing the same and
then you know everyone else is you know
in the fight for to add to their team to
compete so that's what you try to do and
I think it starts by developing your own
young players and then of course you try
to acquire as many good players as you
can and then when players start looking
around and a lot of these players they
know each other from the all-star games
and shared agents and the Team USA so
they build relationships with each other
and then it leads to players joining up
with each other and then right before
free agency is when the most smoke needs
to be separated from fire certainly when
you're just days removed from a draft
and the smoke for a lot of people
looking at Minnesota is at Ricky Rubio
is on the block what can you tell us
about that is that true well now I think
you know if people always try sometimes
you don't know where it's coming from
could be coming from agents a lot of
times it's other teams that are trying
to create things create a market but
when you have good players people are
going to be interested in them and we
look at our team in totality and we know
obviously we have cap space and we feel
like we have a very attractive team and
I think free agents with what to look at
first is the type of money it'll be
available then next thing who are the
players are there and how will I fit in
with them
so that's what we're looking for where
the next step for us is the free agency
piece so how close are you you think
today Warriors coach well you know
you're talking about a team that is its
historic greatness so you know for us I
think we have to take it step by step
and I think they're a good team to study
wasn't long ago where they had 123 games
and they went step by step and of course
when you know it's like in the 40s and
then 51 and then they added Iguodala and
Bogut and guys like that dream on of
course and then once they started
playing great defense the the offense I
think has always been there and you can
never overlook what you know Klay and
Steph have made to that team over a long
period of time they win 73 games and
then they had Durant so I said a lot of
people are chasing them and but for us
it's you know we know we have to improve
defensively and that'll be the next big
step for us well it's no shock you coach
Tom Thibodeau have mentioned defense I
believe just off the top of my head no
fewer than four times in this
conversation so far and I want you to
track that rich well I'll do that well
and and because it's interesting because
I'm wondering and I'm asking somebody
who spent many years as the assistant to
the Jeff Van Gundy Knicks from 96 204 um
when I look at the Warriors team and I
see how many people in a copycat league
are trying to maybe outscore them do you
think there's a possible pendulum swing
back to the days where asses are put on
the floor by enforcer types in the
middle of the lane is there a
possibility that we see that in the
association Tom I think the new rules
you know you're not going to be able to
do that but I think what you can't lose
sight of is how great a defensive team
Golden State is so it's not only their
offense that you have to deal with you
have to deal with their defense but I
think the importance of defense is never
that's never changed if you went back
the last 20 years and you looked at the
conference final
you see they're well-balanced they're
strong on both sides of the ball
but I think you have to take a look at
some things that maybe outside of the
box
to try to you know at least slow Golden
State down some and I don't know if you
can do that that they that team is very
well put together I think you have to
try to make them work for their points
but they shoot the three from places
that you're not accustomed to defending
a step basically one dribble over
half-court and clay same thing that's a
good shot for those guys I had the
opportunity to coach them with Team USA
and they work on it and they showed them
and they make seven you know like I
think you have to be aware alert you
have to challenge you have to have a
multiple effort mentality and I think
the versatility I think the six eight
six nine guys six seven as many of those
guys as you can get that can defend I
think that's important and shoot threes
too I guess right I mean a two or three
because I mean you know the thing is
they're going to put forty threes up and
so if you're if they're making you know
eighteen or twenty and you're making six
that's it that's almost an impossible
deficit to make up no it is a beautiful
thing to watch right a team that passes
so much and the team that's so fluid in
offense and it's it really is a it is a
beautiful thing to watch but part of me
coach misses seeing coaches hanging on
to the ankles of Alonzo Mourning you
know when they're just getting out there
as I'm sure you know that you're talking
about the good old days yes but well is
there is there oh I know you mentioned
the rules but well the rules have
changed the game and I think for the
better it crossed over I mean we're
seeing great basketball but I think some
things probably do have to be tightened
up you know like where we've taken you
know the use of hands and and Chuck's
across the lane where that we've taken
that out and you know the hard files and
I think that's helped open up the game
but then I think if we're going to do
that
I think offensively we have to make sure
that you know we're not allowing players
to travel and carry carry the ball I
think we have to tighten it up there as
well so if you could wave your wand and
change a rule what would that be coach
Tom Thibodeau what could you do if I
gave you the if I give
the floor in front of the the Board of
Governors competition committee however
what do you do I think we you know the
the thing I don't like I think the the
scoring went up three points a game this
year and a lot of it has been the
free-throws I think a little more
clarity and there is going to there's
going to be some contact on every play
particularly on pick-and-rolls
like I hate the play in which the guy
comes off on a pick-and-roll and there's
contact and you know it's marginal at
best and it's an automatic you know the
players in our league are so smart they
figure out very quickly how the games
being called and I don't think any of us
want to see a game in which were you
know looking at 60 free-throws being
shot you know so I think they have to
let a little bit more go on on the
pick-and-roll coverage and just it you
know to tighten up the traveling I think
internationally our players in having
coached with the Olympics our player is
adept very well like I thought we would
be called for a lot of him we weren't
because they adjusted you know they got
the ball out of the hand before they
lifted the pivot foot and it was good
you know so I would say that probably
the you know to allow more contact
marginal contact on the pick and rolls
would that would be the first one the
second one is to tighten up on the
travel calls so by now coach do you
think Jimmy's changed his number or we
call it we had those girls out rich
looking for the we're outside but you're
absolutely going to call him up we have
is that we have his number but we have
an update that number is now unavailable
I was bad very fast oh my gosh you never
know right coaching this Danish you're
gonna hear SOT yeah I'll take my shot at
the title anyway we'll give it a try
coach thanks for calling really
appreciate having me always thank you
that's a coach Tom Thibodeau so Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint